Oh my god, congratulations!
Thank you, thank you
Did you have any idea?
No, I mean, you know Scott
"I sure do love a good surprise"
Ugh, I gotta get me a Southern boy
[Beep]
911, what's your emergency?
Please help me, he's killed everyone, I'm
the only one left
What is your exact location?
75 Lemoyne Street in Echo Park
Please hurry oh my god please hurry
Okay, help is on the way.
Who am I speaking with?
Emily, Emily Brookman
Okay Emily, I need you to stay on the line
with me
Can you tell me what's going on?
My friend texted me from her date, she-she
wanted me to pick her up, and I got here and-and
it was all dark and then I...
I heard her screaming so, so I went in.
And there were all these girls, all these
dead girls.
And then I heard him walking in so I hid with
the bodies
How many bodies?
I don't know there were so many I couldn't
tell.
Please help me
[footsteps]
He's coming.
Okay, Emily, can you get to an exit?
No
Do you have anything you can use to defend
yourself?
No
Okay, Emily, the police are on their way,
they're almost there, okay?
I need you to stay on the line with me, okay?
We were supposed to go get french fries
What?
After bad dates, we go get french fries and
orange soda and then we talk about how funny
these stories will be when we're married
[door creaks open]
Oh my god, he's here
[screams]
Well, well, well.
I sure do love a good surprise
[screaming]
Oh my god, somebody please help me--
[line goes dead, dial tone]